how do you you know PR that person off
the couch and and get them into into
action on something might be hard to
take but just [__] do it whatever it
is you're thinking about the more you
procrastinate about it the less likely
you are to do it so if it's your first
marathon book one just book one cuz as
soon as you've paid your money for it
and it's in 6 months time that's going
to give you some gumption to actually do
something about it but we live in a
world where there's too many dreams that
go missing and you might miss an
opportunity to be here doing this [__]
talking with you like quite literally 4
and a half years ago I was doing [__]
all I was a semi-professional rugby
player pretending to be a model
sometimes like nothing was really
happening but as soon as I took that
first step it suddenly led to the second
and the third and the however many steps
I've taken since but action will always
be any kind of intention